most people are trying to do their best
why do we come up short it's God's fault
that's my new thing I heard you talking
about I want people that stop praising
God on Sunday and hold them accountable
for the amount of mouth breathing
inconsiderate [__] [__] sure that he
makes
and then he blames the devil but the
devil is his former employee that's like
his excuse I never thought of it oh it's
the devil it's like yeah well you made
him why don't you get rid of them God
didn't make the devil didn't he yeah and
he made [__] animals with like
vampire teeth and then other ones with
teeth like ours and their job is to get
ripped apart
and eaten alive I mean he's not a good
he's not a good dude yeah he's not and
he made people who like don't say thanks
when you hold the door for him
and I would go a little further
pedophiles well that's going away
he made kid [__] big [__]
no that wasn't me they listen to the
devil